[Applause]
so last time you were here you were very
pregnant I was plus one yes yeah and
felt a little alone walking out this
time
no how are you sleeping too now right my
baby just turned two a few years ago
yeah
thank you
terrible twos but three major is a real
thing just for what I've heard yeah but
then again he turned two two weeks ago
and as I was leaving to come here he was
just like on the floor just crying and I
was like why are you going to go see
Kelly Clarkson I'll be back it's like I
know they they lay it on sometimes like
why are you leaving totally like
blocking the threshold of the door it's
quite dramatic that means that you were
loved yeah he misses you that's nice too
he's an angel no he's the best he's
being mom's the best but what have you
learned about yourself like since
becoming a mom I mean uh don't be too
rigid in your plans because anytime I
try to hold on to like a timing schedule
nope it just it doesn't work so I try to
be you know go with the flow you have to
take everything as it comes I try to you
know get my sleep where I can
um yeah when I was younger my mom would
always be like Emma I just need to sit
down and I'd be like I don't get it and
now I'm the one being like I just have
to sit down like I totally get the
sitting down thing 100 I always have to
plan my schedule like an hour in advance
so we actually make it on time that's
that's also 100 have to leave an hour
padding if you make it at all yeah right
I'm literally like I'm just not it's
just not happening and I'm gonna come up
with an excuse I'm like we're just not
getting out we're just not coming is the
thing it happens
um and so are you sleeping again like
I'm I'm sleeping again but you know I
wasn't obviously for the first year no
yeah and um and I just all I care about
now is sleep and making my sleep the
most luxurious possible so I'm like yes
eye mask bath face mask like everything
I can do to just cocoon myself to get
the best
four hours sleep I know it so I don't
know to get a solid five in um no it's
so funny because when I was younger I
always felt like I mean I could go like
non-stop yeah I wouldn't sleep for days
no I could let you you sleep you go out
you work you don't care and now I'm like
I only got eight hours so yeah I am
praying I will be a human you hate if I
get less than seven hours yes yeah
totally 100 yeah it will go downhill
very fast um so have you I heard though
that you've always had kind of sleep
issues my son has he sleepwalks you did
you Sleepwalk I you know what I did I
had a little bit of sleepwalking yeah
and that's scary well and I I hope it's
not like hereditary because my mom slept
walk slept walk Sleep Walk sleep walk I
don't really know
I oh there's my mom we were both
Sleepwalkers how about that I'll
redirect that um we were both
Sleepwalkers and actually one time I was
sleepwalking and she was sleepwalking we
actually ran into each other and we were
both so freaked out and we realized we
were both sleepwalking and I was just
like this this can't be good like are
the doors locked what's happening I know
it scares me because I had a friend and
her brother had and he like walked out
on the road and he had no idea he was in
the right so I'm like terrified and we
had stairs in our house no so I'm always
like oh my God don't find the stairs no
well I hope my son's not a sleepwalker
but I mean he's two and we're lucky he
hasn't figured out he can climb out of
the crib because he totally is capable
yeah but he just hasn't which I thought
was very sweet of him that's different
that's different with boys and girls too
they're a little more behind yeah he's
just he's happy to you know just stay in
the crib which is nice for now but I
just know he's gonna climb out one day
and I just hope he doesn't sleep walk on
time enjoy enjoy baby jail while you
have it because once they get out you
were like oh my God no no you can't draw
on the walls no now he knows for the
fourth time open doorknobs and turn on
and off lights so it's like there's a
ghost in my house sometimes like doors
are open lights are I'm like what
happened I just I just turned all this
off and shut this we had a power outage
like I don't know months ago and my son
was so terrified about it so now to say
power he like he goes around our house
and always turns off lights love he love
that energy for you six years old you've
ever seen he turns off every light
because he's afraid that the power won't
come back on I'm like I know there's
gonna be some therapy there in the
future it's fine it's fine
um I heard that you have a gadget though
that you love that helps you read at
night so you don't have like just a
normal reading light or you know I I
don't okay I've gone through every book
light in town and none of them you know
they fall off the page they're not
bright enough you're not going to switch
it off the page and then it's not as
bright on the other page
and also I'm always traveling so I'm
like how can I read in the car and ever
since I was a kid I mean I don't I don't
know about you guys or you but when I
was in the back seat with my mom if you
turn on that light you were you were
dead like like I don't know what it is
about parents where there like if you
touch that light we will we will die and
I'm just so I never I'm like oh God we
want to touch anything in the car yeah I
know what is that about I don't have
that same like I I realize now when I
drive and the lights on I'm like it's
fine like it's really that bad I think I
just um innately became my mom and I'm
like don't touch the light so because
I'm afraid they're gonna leave it on and
I'm not gonna see it okay well this is
gonna wear it on the battery or
something logical my mom was like we
can't drive with that on and that's like
pure chaos
totally but no so I um took it upon
myself to go another route with the book
light and found this amazing light that
you wear around your head and so when
you're looking at the page it's right
there I brought you one so you could
actually see thank you
um I think these are for hiking and
outdoor activities but I use them for
reading um so I have one of these and I
play wolf pack with my children in the
backyard with them and we it's dark out
okay I don't have this specific brand
this is fancy mine is more like you know
it costs six dollars but um and this one
you can also tilt it down to the page
might I add oh my gosh wait you
definitely know what this is do you just
sport this in bed while you read look
down it like look at your book well Ann
look how amazingly hot I look right and
it's very sexy yeah probably on you Emma
I'm like am I um if I could lift my arms
yeah I'm gonna get killed by the way
from my makeup and hair but I'm willing
to risk our friendship over this so now
that your mama are you still getting a
chance to take vacations like you used
to because it took me a while to
actually start doing that again you know
I I well obviously not as much I get to
also travel for work which doesn't count
obviously
because you're busy but I went this uh
after Christmas I went to the snow for
the first time in years yeah and I skied
and snowboarded
I did
um you know I'm mediocre at both oh so
that's cool it's more just my whole
thing was like I
hear people would race down and first of
all I never looked that cool on the
slopes but um but people would always
race down like friends and I'm like it
took us forever to get up here I was
like I'm gonna Coast down I would Coast
like a grandma no well I also thought I
was better than I was like I was kind of
talking to a big game I hadn't I hadn't
been up for a few years I'm like I'm
really good and then I realized I can
only snowboard on my heels and like
facing like I can't go on my toes 100 I
can't count that down yeah I can't turn
yeah I do this yeah and people turn and
go backwards I'm like why do we need to
do that I want to see everything why
would I do that yeah fancy footwork but
no getting off the chair lift getting
off I have to prepare for it from the
moment I get on and usually I just dive
forward like I'd hope for the best yeah
it's the I it's embarrassing watching me
get off the ski lift I fall every time
because I freak out and I'm like maybe
I'll just go on a crawl I just end up
crawling because I get nervous because
it's so fast it's really not that fast
but yeah I hadn't skied it since I was
like 12 because my mom and I used to ski
together but I had that little thing
that you put on the end of your skis
when you're a kid I've never skied only
snowboarded all right well it keeps them
together it's really dorky it's like not
considered cool it keeps it like pie
yeah okay my mom was like you know it's
time to get rid of that and I was like
I'm not and she's like well
um then you then you should find someone
else to ski with so so I started
snowboarding so I finally got back on
skis this year yeah and I was really
feeling myself on you know the the kids
mountain like with the three-year-olds
like I was like I got this i got this I
go up to the top of the other Mountain
lost my ski the instructor was like what
are you gonna walk down and I was like
oh great where do people do that and he
was like no you can't
I was rhetorical I was like where's the
walking path I would love to
um so I had to yeah put that ski back on
and get down the hill and it was it was
not pretty there should be a movie made
about people like us going skiing and
snowboarding because it is hysterical
but it is fun when you're doing it it's
like yeah it is some of it but anyway
um so let's talk about your new movie
because I've been very excited too
because I watched it and it was one of
those movies it's called maybe I do it's
one of those movies where I literally
called like four people after watching
it going just downloading like
everything I was like I was afraid of
getting back in relationships and then I
was also like relieved to not being it
was just it's very thought provoking and
kind of scary yeah like for your
character and then also for the parents
it's yeah because Love Changes yeah I
mean it's it's a story it's a story
about love you know and all different
kinds of love I mean my character she is
or thinks she is like ready to get
married ready to commit her boyfriend is
scared and then you meet their parents
and you kind of see why they are the way
they are and you see that one way is not
necessarily right and one way is not
necessarily wrong it's all heart and
it's all feeling and you just kind of
Wonder like what's going to happen to
all of these people's relationships by
the end of the movie and even how they
all
connected I was like no I was literally
in my like watching it all over my house
going there's no way oh my God it's
happening well what makes us laugh is
that the the people you know behaving
badly in love are not the young people I
will say I know that scared of me Emma I
was like are we doomed I was like are we
all gonna visit people gonna get bored
unhappy I was like but then it was
interesting I loved the even the dynamic
of the the older relationships happening
I loved how it showed like
sometimes people it isn't like like
people always think oh people cheat for
certain reasons sometimes it's just you
want to be heard and you feel like
you're just not noticed anymore the
other relationship not valued and I feel
interesting every character in the movie
has their reasons and you start to
unravel that throughout the movie and
and it also just shows that what I like
is you know obviously you know people
want romantic love we want romantic love
but there's all different kinds of love
I mean you know like love for your child
love for your family love between
friends that feel like family and so I
don't know I feel like we're like we're
coming into a time where I feel like
there's so much different kind of love
people can you know feel valued by it
doesn't just have to be romantic I had
this whole conversation with my
girlfriends because I was like one I
love that it showcased the man side of
it too like William H Macy's character
first of all the level of talent is
insane it's like Diane Keaton it's like
this is Richard Gere and it's everybody
oh and I love that you're doing a movie
with um uh Luke as well because y'all
did all yes I can y'all do the Meg Ryan
Tom Hanks thing in just two movies
together because I love him I love y'all
we have the thank you we have the best
time together no when I have the best
chemistry thank you when when we when I
read this script and they were like
Diane Keaton's doing it Susan Sarandon's
doing it Richard Gere's doing it William
H Macy I'm like did you guys mean to
call me like is this I was like you want
me to be in this and then actually Luke
was one of the last people cast because
they're like who should be your
counterpart I'm like it has to be luke
oh my God and I texted him I was like if
you say no I am coming to find you and
punch you and he was like no I won't I
won't I was like I will be pissed
because there have been a couple other
movies that I'm like do this with me and
we're both like not quite right not
quite right and this I was like if you
say not quite right to Diane Keaton and
Susan Sarandon yeah I'm done and you're
wrong yeah no I just love when actors do
that too I think fans like we all love
that like watching I love it yeah I
always I'm like I always want to see
people that have done these together
reunited I know comforting I was I
turned it on I was like this is day I
was like wait this is the same and I
loved holiday like you way to go because
not few I remember I said this last time
I think but like there are very few
movies that come out on Christmas day
that I feel like really nail it that you
want to watch every year thank you that
is a good one but anyway I love maybe I
do everybody needs to I mean just for
therapy watch maybe I do
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]